the State Department is condemning
deadly terror attacks on churches in
Egypt it calls them barbaric two suicide
bombings killed more than 40 people on
one of the holiest days on the Christian
calendar more than 100 others were
wounded the bombs in tanta and
alexandria blew up during Sunday
services just a few hours apart Isis has
claimed responsibility Mark Phillips is
following the latest developments from
London mark good morning good morning
well Christians make up about 10% of the
Egyptian population and have been
frequent targets of jihadi bombers but
this double attack seems to have had
another motive besides mass murder
it seemed designed to shake the
strongman government of Abdul Fattah
el-sisi which has promised security but
has clearly been unable to provide it
the Palm Sunday service in the st.
George's Church in tanta north of Cairo
in the Nile Delta had attracted a large
congregation of worshippers among them a
bomber the explosion blew the internet
stream of the service off the air and an
instant had killed 27 people here
authorities said the carnage wasn't over
a few hours later at st. Mark's Church
in Alexandria a man with a blue sweater
over his shoulder is denied entry and
told to go through a metal detector the
people unlucky enough to be around it
became the next target both bombings
appeared to be suicide attacks and
responsibility for them was claimed by
the so-called Islamic state the 3-month
state of emergency declared by the al
Sisi government may result in more
pressure on militants operating in Egypt
and an even more severe clamp down on
opposition there after meeting the
former Army General in Washington last
week President Trump took to Twitter to
express his confidence that President
al-sisi will handle situation properly
it's difficult to see where that
confidence comes from el Sisi came to
power bowing to provide security and
these attacks will undermine those
claims Egypt has been operating under
various states of emergency for a year
but that has simply forced the Bombers
to choose softer targets for the
beleaguered Christian minority in Egypt
this was the single deadliest day in
decades
Noora mark thank you so much